die spd hat die bürgerschaftswahl in
hamburg klar gewonnen trotz der verluste
könnten die sozialdemokraten mit ihrer
rot grünen koalition weiterregieren
jedes ergebnis nach der ersten
auszählung demnach kommt die spd auf 39
prozent die grünen auf 24 2 die cdu
landet bei 11,2 prozent die linke kommt
auf 9 1 die afg auf 5,3 prozent und die
fdp
nach derzeitigem stand auf 5,0 hamburgs
alter und neuer erster bürgermeister
peter tschentscher lässt sich feiern die
spd an der elbe muss verluste einstecken
bleibt aber stärkste kraft in der
bürgerschaft jetzt gibt's aber an die
arbeit wir müssen jetzt einen
koalitionsvertrag beschließen der die
richtigen themen und ziele für unsere
stadt festigt der alte regierungspartner
wird wohl auch der neue werten hamburgs
grüne gehen mit einem nahezu
verdoppelten ergebnis gestärkt in die
koalitionsverhandlungen
wir haben die anderen fuhren ziel
getrieben mit unseren themen mit dem
klimaschutz thema mit der verkehrswende
und jetzt auch zuletzt noch mal mit dem
thema offene gesellschaft für die cdu
ein schwaches ergebnis rein rechnerisch
ist sie trotzdem möglicher
koalitionspartner für die spd ort werden
wir uns nicht versperren
denn diejenigen die jetzt verantwortung
tragen uns auch den ball zu spielen
die linke jubelt freut sich auf die
oppositionsarbeit in der hamburgischen
bürgerschaft wir werden mit mehr
abgeordneten höchstwahrscheinlich
einziehen und das ist doch eine super
nachrichten die afd in hamburg verliert
stimmen scheint die fünf prozent hürde
aber überwinden zu können für die
elbliberalen hingegen gibt es noch keine
entwarnung
ralf zimmermann von seefahrt vor dem
hamburger rathaus derzeit liegt die fdp
bei fünf prozent aber heute nacht gab es
eine meldung aus langenhorn das stimmen
möglicherweise verwechselt wurden was
hat es damit auf sich
423 stimmen genau sind bisher der fdp
dort zu gerechnet worden
gehören aber möglicherweise den grünen
da ist möglicherweise die fdp mit den
grünen verwechselt worden
und das könnte
bedeuten dass wenn die fdp ihren
tatsächlichen anteil kriegt dann unter
die fünf prozent fällt weil sie nämlich
zurzeit nur mit 121 stimmen 121 stimmen
überhaupt über der fünf prozent hürde
ist für ganz hamburg und das ist
natürlich extrem wenig das hamburger
wahlsystem ist sehr kompliziert deswegen
wird sowieso das war von vornherein so
geplant heute noch mal alles ausgezählt
tagsüber und es wird erst heute abend
ein amtliches vorläufiges amtliches
endergebnis geben
insofern muss man mal schauen was der
tag noch bringt sicher scheint zu sein
dass die afg drin ist ganz unsicher
scheint zu sein
ob die fdp tatsächlich drin ist in der
hamburgischen bürgerschaft vielen dank
reif zimmermann von seefahrt